[Musique]
dans le jardin créole celle qu'on
appelle cassia latin comme mesurer
jusqu'à 3 mètres de haut
[Musique]
arbuste fournit ses feuilles sa ligne
rangés comme des soldats le long d'une
tige d'environ 70 cm
originaire des caraïbes mais aussi
d'amérique centrale et du sud on la
trouve également en asie du sud est
dans tous ces pays cassis à lattes a
aussi connu sous le nom scientifique de
ces la lata houdart trier est utilisé
pour soigner les mêmes mans
essentiellement des infections cutanées
et la constipation
[Musique]
dans sa composition on prouve en effet
de la louer et médine également présente
comme son nom l'indiqué dans la loue et
vera et de la rime aussi présente dans
la rhubarbe année il s'agit de deux
molécules aux propriétés laxatives
par ailleurs dans de nombreux pays de
l'ain de l'amérique centrale on utilise
les feuilles de senna al adha pour
régler les problèmes de peau comme
l'eczéma les tâches de l'otage
les pmi ou les champignons
en martinique le tarn le pôle agro
ressources et de recherche à mener ses
analyses dans le cadre du projet pas mal
et là encore il a obtenu des résultats
impressionnants sur le traitement
d'infections cutanées il s'est avéré
qu'on a pu tester un géant en
particulier qui est le culte y battait
au yom ha cnes et qui est responsable de
la cne et les résultats ont été positifs
pour un extrait en particulier c'est un
extrait à base d'alcool cet extrait il
pourrait être valorisé dans des produits
cosmétiques pour produire des notions d
crème des crèmes de jour des crèmes de
nuit
pour lutter et traiter la crise
[Musique]
une vraie valorisation économique de
cassia da thao perspective d'autant que
les industries cosmétiques peuvent aussi
envisager de valoriser l'action anti âge
de cette plante sa teneur importante en
antioxydants en fait un excellent moyen
de lutte contre le vieillissement
cellulaire
mais quelles qu'en soient votre visage
il faut toujours être prudent si les
plantes peuvent soigner mieux vous
demandez conseil à votre médecin
[Musique]